president trump says he does not support
a nationwide order to require the use of
masks to slow the spread of the
coronavirus
after some white house officials took
aim at dr anthony fauci this week the
nation's top infectious disease expert
says
he does not believe the president is
trying to discredit him but mr trump is
lashing out at his niece for the first
time
after her tell-all book was published
this week nicole killian is at the white
house with a full round up for us nicole
good morning
hey good morning to you dana and we
haven't heard from the president
this morning but he is speaking out in a
new interview he said he
thinks masks are a good thing but
doesn't agree
everyone should wear one
will you consider a national mandate
that people need to wear masks no i want
people to have a certain freedom
in an interview airing this weekend on
fox news sunday
president trump says he has no plans to
implement a national mass quarter hey dr
fauci said don't wear a mask
our surgeon general terrific guy said
don't wear a mask
everybody was saying don't wear a mask
all of a sudden everybody's got to wear
a mask
and as you know masks cause problems too
we know they work
and that is universal wearing of masks
in a separate interview dr anthony fauci
disputed he was being
undermined by the white house despite a
scathing op-ed this week from trade
advisor peter navarro
and this cartoon posted by senior aide
dan scavino
do you think you have the full backing
and support
of the white house from the president on
down
i do i do i believe i do i spoke to the
president about that i believe i do
democrats allege another top doctor cdc
director robert redfield
is being blocked from testifying next
week at a house hearing on safely
reopening schools
committee chairman bobby scott called it
alarming a white house official tells
cbs news redfield has testified several
times in recent months
and needs to focus on the pandemic
response the truth is not being leveled
at us
the president's niece mary trump
continued her media blitz after
releasing a family memoir this week
disparaging her uncle reacting for the
first time on twitter the president
called mary
a seldom seen niece who knows little
about me says
untruthful things about my wonderful
parents and me
she's a mess as for
being seldom seen i i guess for donald
that is
uh one of the biggest insults you can
hurl at somebody
but i'm i've been fine with it
the white house calls it a book of
falsehoods but nearly a million copies
sold on the first day of release and the
book has
already hit number one on amazon's best
seller list
the book is published by simon schuster
a division of viacom cbs
michelle a lot of people reading that
book nicole
thank you